there was a priest who was a very big
impact on my life who was Theologian who
was frequently on these big panels
discussing theology with other
theologians and one of the other
theologians had mentioned how he he
doesn't believe in the Devil the man I
know got up and he said well I have to
address that right away because this is
scriptural first of all so like if you
don't believe the scriptures I don't
know how you ever became a priest and
then went through a few other things and
then said finished his talk gave his
talk done afterwards he went up to the
priest and said I'm going to pray for
you in a way that you'll come to believe
in the devil and they were all staying
at this Retreat House and that night
there were shrieks coming from that
priest's room
and when they ran to see what was wrong
and that he let them in he said the
devil came tonight
and now I believe